the Justice League Lex Luthor Magneto
the Justice League again it's been a
rough year for superheroes in 2022
here's who's queuing up for Resurrection
in the next few years
like all the other members of payback
mindstormers ruthlessly massacred by
Soulja Boy during his quest for revenge
on anybody remotely linked to his
decades as a prisoner and guinea pig of
soviet-era military scientists from what
the boys lets us see Mindstorms powers
are a rough blend of Charles Xavier and
Jason Weingartz he can hear thoughts
project images into the heads of other
people and induce nightmare-filled
comers well if it's as usual limo
trapped him in an endless nightmare
until he dies of terminal dehydration
evidently his power set does not include
imperviousness to repeated blows from a
dull metal object Mindstorms Cranium
caves right in after a handful of cracks
on the edge of Soldier Boy's Shield
before Soldier Boy turns his skull into
a bowl of face meat stir fry Mindstorm
provides the boys season 3 with two
essential plot points by banishing Billy
to relive his worst memories as a series
of nightmares Mindstorm indirectly
convinces him to nudge Huey away from a
showdown with homelander and onto a for
trajectory also Mindstorm tells Soldier
Boy the true nature of his relationship
to homelander the fact that proves both
unsettling and Darkly obvious
this year part of the team behind 2019's
John Constantine hellblazer reunited for
the three issue Endeavor Suicide Squad
Blaze and they certainly left their mark
on the DC Universe by the end of their
Suicide Squad tale everybody is dead
Superman takes on the story's enigmatic
Arch fiend in the second issue and gets
eaten for his trouble the rest of the
Justice League attacks soon after but
their efforts are much more successful
as you might expect the likes of
Peacemaker king shark Amanda Waller and
Harley Quinn failed to survive this
ordeal although some of their deaths are
much funnier than others of course don't
expect these deaths to stick the events
of Suicide Squad Blaze are established
as occurring in a non-canonical
alternate timeline from the mainline DC
Universe transgender superhero dreamer
first appeared on the CW Supergirl and
finally arrived in DC Comics in Superman
son of Kalel issue 13. while you might
think the issue would focus on the comic
debut of the popular character Neil
really half the issue was spent on
dreamers Recollections of an upcoming
point in the future in which the
villainous Bendix easily knocks off the
entire Justice League plus the joker as
a demonstration of dominance these same
characters seemingly also perished at
the onset of DC's heavily promoted
Summer Event dark crisis it appears 2022
is a year in which DC Comics repeatedly
murders the Justice League then again
Jonathan's probably gonna prevent
whatever causes or the atrocities
dreamer shows him in so we guess it all
comes out in the wash the penguin
swallows a cyanide pill in Batman issue
125 just in time for a witness to see
what looks like Batman strangling him
Savvy fans might presume the flightless
crime mongering creature will get back
to the business of giving Gotham a hard
time before long as they read this issue
after all if Bane only stayed dead for
less than two real world years worth of
comics how long can DC possibly keep the
Penguin on ice it turns out to be quite
a bit shorter since just two issues
later in Batman issue 127 Mr revealed
that Oswald cobblepot did not in fact
die he merely underwent plastic surgery
to reduce his famously beak-like nose
dyed his hair blunt and relocated to
Metropolis under the secret identity of
Paul Meredith Palmer's proprietor of
Blossom's florist
up until season three of the boys all we
really know about black noir is that he
doesn't say much and often takes the
lives of other human beings with
gruesome efficiency in season 3 we
learned that he once fought as a member
of Soldier Boy's team payback it's
falling out with the Patriotic phony
during the 1980s eventually comes around
to bite him in the butt and provide a
basis for this particular season
storyline when homelander finds out Noir
has always known the awful secret of his
parentage he punches clean through Noir
stomach and pulls a bunch of his guts
out as far as deaths on the boys go it's
arguably a little anticlimactic for a
character who's been around since season
one
back when it was the X-Men's primary
villain plenty of folks accused Magneto
of being heartless leave it to thanos's
great uncle to turn a figurative
accusation into a fatal reality for the
master of magnetism then again death is
really more like a suggestion than an
inevitability for a guy like Magneto as
documented in 2019's House of X powers
of X the X-Men have figured out
Resurrection granting de facto
immortality to all mutants always a
Trailblazer Magneto relinquishes his
eternal existence in order to more
effectively co-govern arako the planet
formerly known as Mars not long after
this decision the Eternal Uranus
launches a ruthless Onslaught against
the Iraqi population in a valiant
defense of his people Magneto faces
Uranus and promptly finds himself
lacking a central circulatory organ with
assistance from Storm Max keeps his
blood pumping with a stunning display of
magnetic force and eventually dispatches
Uranus but the effort of thwarting a
planetary threat without access to a
heart proves too much and magneso
succumbs to the gaping wound in the
middle of his chest and X-Men read issue
seven magnesium has dictated that he
shouldn't be brought back but whether or
not he ends up returning to the living
is largely Irrelevant for now the master
of magnetism is decidedly deceased and
he went out in one of the coolest ways
that any Hero has in years
Chadwick Boseman passed away in 2020 but
the on-screen death of King t'challa
doesn't occur in Canon until the soul
destroying first scene of black panther
wakanda forever stricken with an
unexpected terminal illness t'challa
can't access the healing properties of
the heart-shaped herb because killmonger
towards the world Supply in 2018's Black
Panther shuri is on the cusp of
developing a synthetic heart-shaped herb
replacement but doesn't manage to finish
the job in time to save her only sibling
it's instantly the saddest thing that's
ever happened in the MCU in part because
t'challa isn't brought down by
killmonger or Thanos instead his killer
is something entirely real an illness of
the sorts so many non-celluloid people
die from it's an invisible but
omnipresent enemy parts of a world with
a predilection for tragic flukes the
fact that it mimics the actor's real
life death makes it even more gutting he
was
King and black panther to everyone
like panthera calendar forever certainly
compensates for the first black panther
films under utilization of Angela
bassett's Queen ramonda that's
tumultuous anguish and Steely sense of
Duty to her nation and remaining loved
ones provide a number of the movie's
dramatic high points while shuri escapes
into Super Science and shuts off her
emotions to avoid mourning her brother
and processing her grief the wiser
reminder tries to nudge her daughter
into a healthier trajectory sure he's
probably in a better headspace by the
end of the movie birthromonda isn't
around to see it she drowns rescuing
Riri Williams after Neymar blows up the
Royal Throne Room during the attack on
wakanda t'challa established as an
unofficial black panther policy against
Revenge all the way back in 2016's
Captain America Civil War Justice will
come soon enough
Birds after Neymar kills raimonda even
the most pacifists of MCU fans might
find themselves rooting for shuri to put
a sharp piece of vibranium between
namor's neck and the rest of his body
it's a little surprising that it took
Prius Brosnan or his 90s kids know him
James Bond this long to find his way
into a superhero movie and it's equally
surprising to see the Justice Society of
America lending their retro cred to one
of DC's only movies to get a theatrical
release in 2022 while the proto-justice
league came to be in comics first
published in the early 1940s the
wholesome team has experienced Hills and
Valleys of relevance ever since and in a
vacuum it's downright shocking that Kent
Nelson doesn't survive the events of
Black Adam with more than 80 years of
on-again off-again appearances and
monthly Comics Multiple appearances and
animated series as well as a live action
turn in Smallville a golden domed wizard
is at least as famous as Doctor Strange
was before Benedict's Cumberbatch
arrived on the scene but whether or not
would buy tickets to see Brosnan
starring a Doctor Fate Trilogy seems
irrelevant as sadly his abilities to
manipulate space and time apparently
provide little defense against a really
hard punch to the Torso but then again
that is often the case with the matters
pertaining to fate things are not always
as they seem with Dwayne Johnson
promising on Twitter that fans would see
more of the character however with James
Gunn and Peter Safran now in charge
we'll just have to wait to see if it's
still fated to be
overall the modern era soft relaunch of
Jack Kirby's eternals is a mixed bag
director Chloe zile's eternals isn't
landing at the top of an MCU favorite
film list anytime soon meanwhile the
deathless cohort quietly climbed to
prominence in their 2021 comic series
one thing leads to another in 2022's axe
Judgment day and it falls upon Cersei to
demonstrate to a literal Planet
annihilating God that the eternals
aren't necessarily destined to repeat
the same malignant Loops into Infinity
she asks Humanity to judge her for the
scores of people the eternals of
obliviously murdered over the years
Humanity judges her harshly and the
aforementioned wrathful guard waves her
out of existence just about everybody
dies at some point in Judgment day but
crack Cohen Resurrection protocols in
addition to other factors bring almost
everybody back with the major exceptions
of magnito and Cersei you might say that
the moral to Cersei sacrifices that with
the great power comes great
accountability
Titans feels like an arrowverse show if
arrowverse shows that the budget and
energy of late 90s syndicated cable
instead of 2010's network melodrama sure
it's a little cheesy but so what Titans
can take real chances and if they don't
pan out well the show has never had a
glowing reputation to lose in the first
place a dying man is like a cornered
animal that's when they're most
dangerous
in a move that clearly requires
intestinal fortitude and or utter
Madness Titans brings the board widely
recognizable actor Titus Welliver to
play one of DC's most essential big bads
and almost immediately kills him off
with a magic snake in the season 4
premiere the Titans are summoned to
Metropolis where Connor Kent has led to
believe he'll finally meet the source of
half the DNA he was cloned from Superman
when the gang arrives Superman's out on
a mission in the middle of space
somewhere but Lex Luthor super boys are
the Clone dad offers to catch up instead
though initially hesitant to partake in
fatherson bonding with the world's worst
super villain Conor eventually agrees to
the meeting where he learns that the man
of Steel's greatest foe will be dead
from Kryptonite poisoning within six
months Lex tells Kana he'd like to spend
what time he has left getting to know
his only child and bequeath's Conor
ownership of lexcorp right before the
aforementioned magic snake appears in
Lex's esophagus and strangles him from
within
first appearing in 2001's Action Comics
issued 775 Manchester black has come a
long way since the snarky and homicidal
early days originally the leader of the
elite a group of crime fighters who turn
into Superman's enemies once they find
out he won't let them do murders
Manchester accepts an offer from
Superman to join a new version of The
Authority sadly Manchester is in some
degree of Cahoots with Lex Luthor
throughout his affiliation with soops
Lex eventually explodes Manchester's
brain to a race Superman's secret
identity from the global population's
memory because well because that's the
sort of thing that happens in comics
sometimes
[Music]